when are we getting that full-length
album I saw you tweeted like I'm nervous
to share because you want the songs to
be so good
yeah I get I get a bit in my head
because my fans are really important to
me and I don't let them down and I don't
want to let myself down and I don't want
to put out anything that I'm not
completely in love with so I think
that's why it's been taking me a little
bit of a longer time I'm also a bit of a
perfectionist and then I self-sabotage
that a bit too so like I was just kind
of a mess in my head all the time so
it's very soon so doing that getting it
ready Julia Michaels hard at work on her
first full-length album and she tells
Edie it's coming soon but 24 year olds
as also pen case for artists like Kelly
Clarkson Britney Spears and her close
pal Selena Gomez can't keep my hands to
myself I do have to ask you because
Selena Gomez's fans would be very upset
if I didn't are you in the studio with
her she keeps teasing new music we're
dying to know if you guys are working
together again uh no no I'm not
she's amazing and I think she wants to
do her own thing
and have her own words and her own
expressions and and I think that's
amazing
I want her to flourish yeah she deserves
it she does everything I love that
friendship that you guys have it's
always fun to see the dancing videos in
the studio she's everything to me I
wouldn't I wouldn't be doing this
without her
Michael's also co-wrote Selena's ex
Justin Bieber's chart-topper sorry
you've written for so many incredible
people is there a song maybe that you
wish you didn't give up there may be one
or two that I'm not going to name but no
I think everything happens for a reason
and I think every song is meant to be
where it's meant to be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]